la protesta duró unos 10 minutos este
domingo un grupo de afganas se reunieron
para reclamar la participación de las
mujeres en la vida pública pero tras un
breve enfrentamiento verbal con un
combatiente talibán las mujeres se
marcharon
lo que desató la protesta es la última
restricción impuesta a las mujeres por
los nuevos gobernantes el domingo las
empleadas del gobierno de la ciudad de
kabul han recibido la orden de quedarse
en casa
para los puestos que puedan estar
reemplazados por hombres les dijimos a
las mujeres que se quedaran en casa
hasta que la situación se normalizará
sus salarios serán pagados
con eso esta decisión es otra señal de
que los talibanes que tomaron kabul el
mes pasado están imponiendo su dura
interpretación del islam a pesar de las
promesas iniciales de tolerancia a paul
y bonnie and i say es que no se puede
suprimir la voz de las mujeres afganas
manteniendo las en casa restringiendo
las así como no permitiéndoles ir a la
escuela la mujer de afganistán de hoy no
es la mujer de hace 26 años de rostock
causa de rosso y pixar y es que los
alumnos de primaria de kabul regresaron
el sábado a las aulas con salas
separadas por sexos pero las niñas
mayores fueron excluidas de volver a la
escuela hasta nueva orden
en otra muestra del progresivo
establecimiento de una ideología de
línea dura los talibanes cerraron el
ministerio de asuntos de la mujer y lo
han sustituido por un ministerio para la
propagación de la virtud y la prevención
del vicio un nombre que recuerda el
departamento que impone una estricta
doctrina religiosa durante el primer
gobierno de los talibanes hace dos
décadas